[Musik]
hey leute heute gibt es ein besonderes
video ein wonach ihr so lange gefragt
haben seit um gelungen zwei jahren
fragte mich klick zeig uns dein bürger
rezept ich habe schon die eine hälfte
eines versprechens erledigt und zwar
haben wir bürger brüder spannendes
abgedreht die müssten jetzt auch schon
online sein und jetzt kommt die zweite
hälfte jetzt zeige ich euch nämlich die
bürger pettys so habt ihr zwei videos
könnt immer wieder darauf zugreifen und
ich finde ja auch bei bürgern kann man
so viele varianten machen man kann
kommentierte zwiebel nehmen kann
guacamole nehmen man kann pettys aus
hackfleisch oder man wundert sich ein
hähnchen partie es geht einfach alle
verfolgen es gibt so viel und es kommt
alles noch wir haben jetzt gestartet und
machen uns das jetzt zur aufgabe euch
die besten burger rezepte zu liefern
und hier sind auch schon direkt die
zutaten bei den rinder petit ist das
aller aller wichtigste das fleisch hier
nehmt ihr 20 prozentiges also mit 20
prozent fettanteil allerhöchstens 25
prozent anteil darf es haben mehr aber
auch nicht und ist zufällig alles andere
darunter wäre auch wiederum zu trocken
deshalb benutzt am besten 20 prozentige
und hier habe ich jetzt noch salz und
zwiebel granulat am wichtigsten ist
natürlich hier das salz das hier ist
optional aber versucht es mal mit
zwiebel granulat ish mit unglaublich
lecker
es gibt jetzt auch schon direkt dazu und
was ebenfalls sehr sehr wichtig ist dass
pfeffer dann nimmt er am besten den
frisch gemahlen aus der mühle
[Musik]
und mehr brauchen bürger partie nicht
ein bisschen sogar noch drei standard
zutaten einmal das fleisch das sehr
hochwertig sein sollte salz und pfeffer
und zwiebel granulat ist wirklich die
vierte optionale zutat und da könnt ihr
auch keine frischen zwiebeln verwenden
also jetzt nicht frische ziel in reiben
und da rein und das geht nicht da muss
es schon granulat sein ansonsten einfach
drauf verzichten
jetzt ziehe ich mir meine übergroßen
hand schon wieder haben sie falsch
gesorgt hat ist aber nicht schlimm
und jetzt kneten wir das ordentlich
durch das fleisch habe ich jetzt drei
bis vier minuten lang schön
durchgeknetet jetzt hat sich richtig
schön verbunden und als nächstes formen
verdi pettys ich zeige euch mal wie das
dann am ende aussehen wird
also das ist jetzt eine partie mit 150
gramm fleisch das finde ich persönlich
optimal und das mache ich jetzt auch so
dass ich mir dass abhängige das heißt
ich habe ziehe meine waage und gibt da
immer 150 gramm rein
[Musik]
jetzt sind ihr euch das fleisch und
formt es einmal in der hand zu einer
kugel also ich hab jetzt kein petty
forma ich persönlich brauche das nicht
immer ehrlich zu sein ich zeige euch
hier ist nämlich ganz einfach ohne geht
und so spart ihr euch auch noch mal ein
bisschen platz in der küche ist habe ich
das zu einer kugel geformt gibt es hier
auch meine saubere arbeitsfläche und
versucht das jetzt noch mal so ein
bisschen schöner und an den seiten zu
drehen damit damit das an den seiten
noch keine risse bekommt jetzt einfach
flach drücken
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann mit der größe
zufrieden seid und mit der dicke denkt
dran das wird alles noch ein bisschen am
ende vorne dann könnt ihr in der mitte
mit dem finger ein kleines loch
reinmachen
so schrumpft es dann ein bisschen
weniger in der pfanne unsere fertig
geformten burger pettys com jetzt für 30
minuten in den kühlschrank lassen sie
sich später dass sie besser anbraten und
wenn ihr an dieser stelle auf sagt ich
möchte das jetzt ganz einfach einfrieren
dann macht es auch an der stelle man
könnte ja bevor aus ein bisschen mehr zu
bereiten und dann nach bedarf einfach
raus und wir sehen uns gleich wieder
jetzt geht es weiter an der
beschichteten pfanne die habe ich jetzt
richtig stark erhitzt und jetzt geben
wir unser burger partie ohne fett einmal
in die pfanne und braten das von beiden
seiten an und dabei so wenig wie möglich
wenden
[Musik]
schon jetzt ist gerade so den rest an
dass wir sind unsere ersten zwei
exemplare die werden gleich vernascht
die sind jetzt schon ein bisschen
abgekühlt das stört nicht persönlich
aber gar nicht aber da brate ich jetzt
noch ganz frisch fleisch an und dann
genießen wir das oder hamza großen es
schon fast dunkel geworden man sitzt
nicht so ganz aber wir sind den ganzen
tag schon brandes zu filmen und haben
schon ganz sondern sind super maul und
wollen einfach noch rein weißen und das
machen wir gleich auch ja und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß ihm
nachmachen ich werde euch noch ganz ganz
ganz viele varianten zeigen da dürft ihr
euch sehr gerne drauf freuen
das ist jetzt so der kiki classic
variante also für mich immer ganz lecker
mit dem karamellisierten zwiebeln und
mit ein bisschen käse barbecue sauce und
dann bin ich total glücklich
es gibt ja richtig viele varianten und
haben einfach gesagt haben sie hat auch
nur so gute ideen mit nachos und käse
soße dann zeigen wir euch dann alles in
aller ruhe
jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz ganz wichtig
wir können gleich richtig schön
brainstorm beim burger essens machen wir
dann schreibe ich alles auf und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz ganz viel spaß
und nachmachen georgia und nimmt die
infobox das schreibe ich euch alle
genauen mengenangaben noch mal rein
hinter das dem video auf jeden fall
einen daumen nach oben in die bis
hierhin geschaut und es euch gefallen
hat und dann freue ich mich natürlich
auch wenn im main kanal kostenlos
abonniert dann verpasst er auch keine
burger rezepte und ich wünsche euch
jetzt wie gesagt noch einen
wunderschönen tag anzufassen nachmachen
und bis zum nächsten mal auf die gis
kitchen tschüss
[Musik]
okay leute heute okay leute heute ist
echt ein seltsamer tag jetzt stehe ich
hinter der kamera
und da haben sie macht euch im test mal
gucken was er sagt menschen
hallo hallo willkommen plattform grund
dass ich mal von das duo da steht mein
lieblingsessen
das gleiche problem beschreibt den
geschmack des bootes einfach das so
schön weil ich mein für fische rissen
weißt du was das musste jetzt jeden tag
nicht beim manchmal kommt mit so
genannten aber er verabschiede ich mich
jetzt aber das ist ungewohnt ist hier
stehen viel spaß beim backen und
polemisch vergessen instagram treffen
und cherokee